Hi, I'm Scouter John, and I'm a Scoutmaster with Troop 358 and Signsville, Indiana.
This edition of the Scoutmaster podcast is sponsored by backers just like me.
And now for you, Scoutmaster.
A week or so ago at our Scout meeting, I had my Scoutmasters minute. at the end of the
meeting there,
I substituted in a quick ghost story and it was called The Summer with No Cat.
I don't know about you, but around here we've had a lot of snow days this year.
I'll bet you, if you're listening to me, you have too.
And so I told the Scouts my scary, scary story about the year you know, back in
the olden days, when there were so many snow days one year that school just went
all the way through to September and nobody got to go to scout camp,
Scared them pretty good.
I think they probably figured out in the end. the old man was just pulling their leg.
but wow, it's getting kind of serious, isn't it?
Oh, my
Well, spring will be here someday.
It might only last a day or two, but it'll be here.
Hey, this is podcast number 211..
Hey,
Hey.
Welcome back to the Scout Master Podcast.
This is Clark Greene.
Let's take a look at the mailbag here.
I heard from Dave Long, who's an assistant scout master with Troop 68 and an advisor
with crew 382 in Onalaska, Wisconsin,
And he wrote in to say just a word of encouragement and thanks from a new backer.
I've been following the podcast for some time and finally got caught up.
I can appreciate the work involved in crafting the podcast and doing your other duties.
Thanks so much, Dave.
Thanks for becoming a backer.
We'll talk about that in a second.
I heard from Rob Knapp, who's a scout master with Troop 348 in Reiner, Virginia,
And he said: thank you for all the time you put into your blog.
It's truly a wonderful gift. after listening to many of your podcasts,
I feel like you're an old friend.
Well, thanks, Rob. so much for your kind words.
It's always good to hear from everybody.
Heard from David Copeland, who got in touch over Facebook and said:
became a backer today with an investment.
The resource is. inspiration over the years have been priceless.
Certainly encourage anyone that gets value from it to give back.
Thanks, David.
David Copeland, that's a familiar name.
He's a long time reader and listener.
And, David, thank you so much.
James Keith is with Scout Troop 25 in Martinsburg, West Virginia,
And he says, as always: thanks for all of your efforts. on behalf of Scouts and
Scouters everywhere,
I've encouraged my patrol leaders council to read the Green Bar Life articles.
Well, thanks, James.
I hope they find them interesting.
I hope they find them useful.
If you haven't looked into them, I've talked about them a few times on the podcast
And we have the author of the Green Bar Life articles at scoutmastercgcom on the
podcast to talk about them a little bit:
Enoch Hysie. Enoch's a 19-year-old Eagle Scout who has fresh in his memory his
experiences as a youth leader
And he's sharing some really great information aimed at youth leaders and scouts who aspire
to youth leadership
And I want you to make sure that you let them know about Enoch's work.
So go to scoutmastercgcom and look for Green Bar Life
And you'll see a growing number of articles that Enoch has produced there.
Now I've been talking with Enoch about setting up a live chat so that guys can sign
on and they can ask Enoch questions and they can have a discussion about youth
leadership or whatever is going to be useful to them.
Keep your ears open.
Hope to launch that very, very soon.
I promise to tell you about how to become a backer
If you find what we offer on the blog and the podcast to be helpful to you and
useful to you. you can return the favor by helping me make it possible
By becoming a scoutmastercgcom backer.
The money that backers pay goes to support the blog and the podcast and
defray the expenses of producing and publishing them.
And boy I'll tell you, I just really appreciate everybody who steps up
to help make this possible.
And within the past week, let me thank the following new backers:
Mark Eschen, David Copeland, James Keith and Peter LaRue.
And Peter LaRue, by the way, is a South African scouter
And he has a great blog about pioneering called Ropes and Pulse.
Google that Ropes and Pulse
And you're going to get some great pioneering information from Peter LaRue.
Well, in this week's podcast I've got another interview for you.
Yep, last week we talked to Best Cook with the Cambridge Garden Guides
down there in Australia and we're going to change our tune a little bit this week
And we're going to welcome back our old pal, Arlen Ward, who is a scoutmaster
out in Colorado and started a brand new scout troop last year.
From time to time I've gotten Arlen to come and talk to us on the podcast.
Let us know how the troops going and what it's like to be a brand new
scoutmaster, brand new troop,
And that's going to take up the remainder of the podcast.
So let's get started, shall we?
And now our next episode of the Colorado experiment.
Welcome back to the podcast,
Our old pal Arlen Ward, who is a scoutmaster of Troop 17 out there in Colorado.
It's been a little while since we've talked with Arlen, but he started this troop
just about a year ago,
Isn't that right, Arlen?
I think that's what we decided. we would tell everybody:
Yeah, it's been almost a year.
We've just finished Recharter for the first time and we're off and running. at this point.
We're old hands at everything. I guess
There's no new challenges that we've done at all. at least one
Let's review quickly.
You made a decision to go ahead and to start a new troop in your town.
You started with how many scouts?
We started with six. I think
The very first meeting we had, we took over the community room at the local REI and
just invited everybody and said: you know, if you're interested, come by,
We'll figure out what we're going to do from there.
And I think we had six families at that point.
And then the word got out: several boys who had been scouts but had left
scouting, decided that what you were doing sounded interesting. and they showed up.
Yeah, we originally thought that we would kind of muddle through that first year
and tell Crossover, which was actually last night, and work with the other guys
on advancement and activities and kind of get them in the mode of doing scouting,
before we got this influx of some weeblos-
And the weeblos were really the reason that we did this.
These were kind of the cohorts that my son was with.
The Den Leaders and Assistant Cubmaster were all friends of mine
and we started making arrangements last year to start a troop
And we thought, like I said, there was going to be just a few half dozen or so.
And then, you know, they brought some more friends. and then some other people
heard about it and then they brought some more friends
And before you knew it we had 20-plus guys on the troop.
And where are you right now?
You say you just had Crossover. right,
Right,
Crossover. there were eight that joined our troop last night
And I think it takes us to about 30.
From six to 30 in a year. first of all, you've got to feel good about that,
but there has to have been some growing pains along the way?
Oh, there were. yeah, there were a lot of growing pains,
especially since there wasn't any traditions to fall back on.
I mean, in some ways that was great, because we could set the tone
as far as who answers what question.
I'm understanding that most of the questions that they asked me,
I'm just going to turn around to them and say,
well, you know, it's your troop,
What do you want to do?
Yeah,
But we didn't have the traditions of well, how did we do this before?
They decided in May of last year that they wanted to go to summer camp,
came to the adults and said: you know, we've decided
we really would like to go to summer camp if at all possible.
So May is pretty late in the season to be looking for a summer camp.
So we looked around and talked to Matt Myers,
actually the council executive in Wyoming,
and he was able to help us out and get us into their last week
of summer camp,
You know. so, using that experience, we're like:
well, we have to obviously worry about summer camp
way earlier than that,
And so we started looking at summer camps in January,
And it turns out that that's not even early enough,
because the camps that they selected to go to.
most of them were full by the time we were able
to nail down a week that they wanted to go.
That turned out to be kind of a big struggle. this year
There's been some challenges with the schedule.
How about with families?
How's that working?
You know, the more families you get,
the more challenging it becomes,
The more diverse the group right.
Those first six families were very dedicated
to making sure that this troop worked,
You know. and then as it goes along,
I mean we have some had one scout that joined.
he came twice, filled out the paperwork,
brought it back the second time.
You know, we started going through things,
thought, you know, taught them a few things,
got them into a patrol and stuff like that,
And we have never seen them again.
Yes,
The famous disappearing scout.
They go from state to state,
Yeah,
And they show up at your meeting for a couple of weeks
and then they go away and it's time for them to move on
and they go haunt another troop,
The same, yeah, the same guy,
Yeah,
He's just going. but you know
there was no response via email or phone calls
as we tried to reach out to him, you know.
And like, like you said, it's nothing new.
It was just there are some families
that understand scouting better than others,
So we've had to adjust along the way
and make sure that we're explaining things
to those that haven't been around scouting.
Yeah,
I mean, 30 years in, I don't think
you can over-explain things.
A lot of the things we don't even know
what it is that we need to explain.
And then the only way we find that out is:
you know, you end up with frustrated families
that are like what is going on?
You know, I don't understand any of this,
And you kind of talk through the way
that they have things organized
and it's like the light bulb goes on.
Oh, okay,
Well, you know, and so we obviously need to make sure
that everybody knows where the calendar is,
where the parents can get information
about their scout, for whatever
shocking reason doesn't come back
and tell them everything that's going on.
You know, so communication's been a big one, for sure.
How about just like mechanical stuff,
like finances, advancement gear, stuff like that?
As a troop, with no real equipment to start with,
we've been trying to figure out how that works.
There's enough scouts that have tents
that could bring their own tents,
and then you can pair everybody else up.
The big challenge that we have
is around winter equipment and things like that.
Yeah, you need it. in Colorado,
Basically, from about November December timeframe
through about March,
there's some real questions about
how are you going to do your winter camping,
And so it's just a matter of finding out
what works best for our troop
and the way that they work.
You've got to try out two or three things
and figure out which one really works.
Sometimes that's half the fun.
Yeah, I mean, these guys have had a great time.
Originally they had scheduled a trip in December
and it was going to be like 10 below zero
for the overnight trip,
So this is going to be their first winter camping experience,
And so when I talked to the PLC about this,
it was like, okay, I have real concerns
around what's coming up this next weekend.
How do you guys want to handle it?
And they decided that instead of going up Friday,
they decided to turn it into a day trip instead,
And so we left really early Saturday morning.
We went up and went snowshoeing-
about six and a half seven miles total.
They stopped and cooked their lunch at the halfway point.
They made it through it.
There were some lessons learned along the way
as far as how to stay warm
and how to stay dry and stuff like that.
But it wasn't as risky as having them
then spend the night up there that next night
when they're cold and miserable.
So the PLC dealt with it when it was brought to their attention
and I'm supposed to be looking out
for the safety and well-being part.
And yet at the same time I wasn't overriding their plans.
I was just kind of explaining through what the challenges were.
How about money, How about finances and things.
We're just kind of making that up as we go.
Yeah, I think everybody does that.
That was when we did our Journey to Excellence
scorecard for this year.
That was one that we got dinged on
because there's one on there
that the troop has a budget.
So I turned to the community chair and said:
do we have a budget?
A what?
And he goes well, sort of,
Because we didn't really know
what costs were associated with things.
We started based off
of other people's experiences
with other troops
and said, well, this troop does it this way
and this one does it this way.
Let's kind of pick what we think works the best out of that
And run with it
And then adjust as necessary.
Now the troop now is to a size where
we have a committee
And before it was really just
the committee chair took care of a lot of things
and I took care of the Scout master side of things.
And we've come to the point where
we've identified other things
that the Scouts can
be involved in.
We did a popcorn fundraiser in the fall.
The adult that had volunteered
to kind of organize all of the popcorn fundraising.
he came to me and he goes. you know,
I've been looking at this and I don't see
a reason why we can't have a Scout run this.
They want to do a Scout fundraiser,
They can run it. I would be more than happy
to look over their shoulder, give them advice
along the way That's to be taken to the PLC
and say: look, you know, you guys want to do
a popcorn fundraiser. Here's,
you know, here's your option.
You guys figure out who's going to do it.
How about other administrative things
like advancement and stuff like that?
How's that worked out?
It has its own hiccups along the way as well,
You know. I think for a while
our advancement reports
weren't being submitted
the correct way. The committee chair,
to his credit, was able to get that
fixed. but you know,
navigating the systems that are in place
has been a bit of a challenge along the way.
From a boy, the boy's standpoint,
their patrol leaders and senior
patrol leader, you know they're
empowered to do a lot of the
advancement stuff up through
first class and they've really taken to it.
From an adult standpoint
it's been less of an issue
because it has been handled at the
scout level and they've taken ownership
of their advancement. They seem to be doing really well.
Of course we do have some scouts that
it's not a priority to them
and the associated
frustrated parents
that are
worried that their son isn't
advancing as fast as the other
guys that are the same age or whatever,
and especially the ones that come from
Cub Scouts, because they're used to.
when everybody hits third grade
they all do this, and when they hit fourth grade
they all do this. and then you get to
Boy Scouts and it's like, well, you've got
a couple of them that are really gung-ho
and they're constantly chasing people around
to sign off their book, and some of them
that probably couldn't find their book if
there was a hundred dollar bill in it for them.
The key part
is let's get them out there
doing things. I said you know, attending
the outing isn't important to me.
Attending the outing will make a difference
as to how they approach scouting.
and there's families
that have jumped on that and
pretty soon they've got patrols
bonding together, working on advancement
together, going through books together
with no adults involved, And some of the other ones.
I've talked to the parents a couple of times.
said: you know, look, I understand
that you have a goal for him:
to get to Eagle. I said you know
you have to realize that the
benefit isn't in the Eagle, The benefit
isn't in the experience.
I said I can't promise you that he'll bank it
there. If he's engaged
and having a good time, he's going
to get the benefit anyway, one way or the other.
Right, right,
You're getting ready to close the books
on the first year.
The $64,000
question is:
would you do it again?
Oh, in a heartbeat. I'd be more prepared
if I were
to do it again. But
you know I had a scout that
his parents were concerned
and he was concerned about being
away from home, And so they said: okay,
he can go on the camp out, He'll come up Friday with
you guys and we'll come up on Saturday night and pick him
up, And he called them
from the campsite on Saturday
afternoon and said:
don't come get me
To see that it makes it worth it.
You've got 17-year-old life scout.
that's our SPL. You know he comes up and
shows me these little
tenessential hang tag things that he made
and laminated to give
to each of the scouts, or give groups
of them to each patrol so they can give them to the scouts
before the camping
trip, and to see him
excitedly showing them off and saying: look,
I put these together. I think they're going to be
really useful and, you know,
taking ownership of things that nobody
had to remind them about. They're no longer asking
me, what are we doing at the meeting this week?
and seeing that after the fourth
or fifth or seventh time that you've
talked them through, that you know the eighth
time they don't come
ask you and they just do it.
You know that's
the stuff that I'm looking at going. yes, okay,
It's working,
sort of. So
you would definitely do it again.
You wish that you could be a little more prepared.
I don't know if anybody can be.
You know I
tried to be. you know like some
of the things that I thought were going to be important
aren't Well. give me
an example:
What are we doing in the meetings?
I mean, I had
visions when we started this of
wonderful flag ceremony, openings,
patrols sitting
in these nice, neat rows
with patrol leaders reporting
on the stuff that they'd been up
to, breaking off to do different
things, gathering together to do
some sort of inter patrol competition- I mean the stuff
that's on the agenda, that
the training shows you right, that
here's what a Boy Scout troop meeting is supposed to look
like, you know. and I
showed that to our PLC and they went,
okay, Oh, that's nice.
That's nice, Mr Ward, Yeah, that's great.
Then they looked at me and said:
do we have to fill this out? I said
only if you think it's useful. I said this is just
an example. Your troop meetings can look
completely different. They're like: all right, They filled
them out by putting the date on them,
What they're going to cover that night,
in the title block,
And then I think which patrol
was doing the opening flying ceremony,
and I think that was it. Yeah,
they've never looked at him again. So
so be it, you know.
So my expectations about meetings are
different, right? Well, let me.
let me unpack that for a moment, because
I think this is really, really important.
So you go in
with a full head of steam and very idealistically
say we're going to start a scout troop.
But you know, you're not
just an idealist. You know
that this is going to be a challenge And
it's going to be a little bit difficult.
But no matter what we do, we're all
going to have some
idealized picture in our minds
of exactly what this is supposed to look
like. And then we're going
to meet with- I'll call
it- disappointment in the fact that
it doesn't end up being exactly
as we pictured it. As a
matter of fact, you know, instead of
the solemn flag
ceremony and the patrols all standing in
their nice neat rows, it's more like
everybody running around the room with
their arms over their head, screaming.
I've actually seen that meeting. I think.
Yeah, I mean, it's
not even that. it wasn't exactly
what I was thinking it was going to look like,
but it was vastly
different. And the things
that make for a successful meeting
are completely different in my
mind now than they were
before we started this.
Originally it was
that they would have
a spirited patrol competition and everybody
would be having a great time.
And now the things I look for
are: you know, I
told my senior patrol leader
a month ago. I said: you know, at this
point you have no business teaching
everybody at the same time
anything. I said you should have
your patrol leaders teaching their patrols.
Your job is to make sure that
the patrol leaders have what they need
in order to be successful in doing that.
You hit 20 boys
in a room
in mass. you can't teach
them anything,
I can't teach them anything, and
I've done a few of these.
But
you get them into groups of 5-8
in the patrols and all of a sudden
they're paying more attention,
they're moving at a speed that's more conducive
to the guys that are in that group
and the patrol leaders are challenged a little
bit more because they're put on the spot
for making sure that they accurately
describe whatever the skill is that
they're working on. So for me,
when I look at a troop meeting
and say you know how
successful are they being? I'm looking
at: are the patrols working
as patrols, as a senior patrol
leader and the troop staff doing
their part to make sure that everybody
is, you know, in kind of making sure things are flowing
along, Which wasn't the case
before. you know, before I thought you know, successful
troop meetings were, you know boys
that could rattle off the Ten Essentials
and tie a square knot behind their back,
blindfolded and you know, and
the scout skills part of it, But turns
out that they learned the scout skills part of it
when they're out on the camping trip.
It's such an important distinction
and I think it flummoxes
a lot of people. It can be really
frustrating for a lot of folks.
If you don't see what you're expecting
to see, you doubt
whether or not you actually
should be doing this at all.
And I wonder about those ghost
scouts that show up and then disappear
after a couple of meetings. If you know they
had an expectation from a family
point. are they doing
scout stuff in the meetings? and then
they go to these meetings that look like chaos
and a bunch of boys
just screwing around and not seeing
the same things that I'm seeing in it
and decided to waste their time for their family
and they're disappearing before
we get that knowledge
to the parents that this is a lot more
chaotic than Cub Scouts.
I know you don't think that's even possible, but
yes, it's true. you know
These aren't nice,
neat meetings. This is messy
and ugly and frustrating
to adults on every level.
I mean, there's still times I have to bite my
lip. Yeah. well,
you and me both, Yeah, and
so I know that the parents are looking
and they're going. did these guys even know what they're doing?
I wouldn't worry about the ghost scout, because all she
need to do is go to ghostscoutorg
and see what they're coming back And you'll see the schedule.
Like I said,
these guys rotate throughout the country.
You can see
by district and troop number
the schedule where they're going to show up at your meeting
for like two meetings and then disappear.
I wouldn't worry too much about that.
The family stick around long enough to go where the boys
are going out on a couple of outings with the troop.
They start to see it. You know they're coming back
jazz and energized. You know why are you excited?
Well, we got to cook,
you know, breakfast, sausage on a stick,
and so we didn't have to do dishes and we think we're
geniuses, Right, And they're like: well, you know,
hey, he's having a good time, Great.
You send them to camp out a couple of
times and you go on the third one. you know the
Scoutmaster saying, no, no, you were setting up over
here and they're setting up over there,
And you kind of look at it with trepidation
and realize that they have their camp
set up and they're making their dinner
and and they not once
have come over to ask what they're supposed to
be doing, and they start to relax
And a few months into it they're, they're kind of
ready to start, but then it repeats itself
with every, every new set of challenges.
Right, As soon as you get one
group that's competent, then it's
time for the incompetent group to move
in and start the process
all over again. Well, you know, I had
a scribe come up to
me. He's been a scribe for a month now
and he says he says I,
he says I don't want to be scribe anymore.
Like, oh,
I was like, well, you need to talk to the
senior patrol leader because I got no control over.
and I said, well, why, what are you
worried about? He goes, I'm not good at it. I said
I've seen you send out emails
to the troop, I've
seen you taking notes and
be able to respond to questions at the PLC
meeting. You know he was just kind of frustrated
and so I said I said you know, you realize
that everybody is learning their positions.
I said all of the patrol leaders and all
the, you know the senior patrol leader and everybody
else that's in a leadership position.
they're learning it as they're going,
So we don't expect you to be perfect
when you get the job. I said, you know,
we hold that for, you know, six
months from now, Right, When you're done.
But when you, you know,
I expect you to be better at it
than you started and
and learn along the way. I said
there's nothing about this troop that
that's perfect,
You know. I said, believe it or not, your
scout master is not perfect. and he kind of
laughed and I said, no, really,
That's
the part that I think,
from the voice
standpoint, that you know, do you want to run
for patrol leader? Well, I don't think I would
be good at it. I don't know what I would do
as patrol leader. Well, that's okay. You want
to learn how to be a patrol leader? Why not be
one? Easier for me to get
across to the parents than it is to the
scouts, because they don't want to mess things up
in front of their peers. Yeah, they're pretty
sensitive about how they appear.
I have boys come up to me and you know
I want a leadership position. I said, well, just
be a leader, Yes,
Well, what do you mean? You know, just do the
things that a leader will do and the
position will find you. You know, they get
a little aggravated with their inability
to do some things. How do I make these guys be
quiet? They won't listen to me. Well,
just keep on after it and, believe
me, things will work themselves out.
If you want to be a patrol leader, be a
patrol leader. You know, I can't put you
through a training course or anything like
that. that's going to help you significantly
to get through the process that you're
going through right now. That seems to work
more often than not. You know, we talked
this week at our troop meeting the same
thing that Enoch had pointed out in the
scout circle, which was
deliberate enthusiasm. Yeah,
I had pulled a couple of patrol leaders
aside and mentioned that. I said
you know what does deliberate enthusiasm
mean to you? Because they were just kind
of hanging back, feigning lack
of interest in anything. You know,
because if I don't care, then it doesn't matter
if I mess it up, right, Because I could say
I just didn't care
And talked about. you know
how much of a difference
just acting enthusiastic
makes. I said, and
before too long: you are enthusiastic
about what's going on, because it's a lot
more fun to go through life with
enthusiasm than it is to be moping
around and pretending like you don't care.
And it made a difference even with
those couple of guys You saw, more
engaged with their patrols. And, speaking of patrols,
that's been one of our biggest
challenges.
And starting with six, you have one
patrol. Then, when you get to the point
where they needed two patrols-
the you know the PLC-
you're like: okay, well, how are you going to handle this?
Right, Do you think they need to
be in two patrols? Yes, Well, how do you
divide them up into patrols? And that was their question
to me. So how do you do that? Well,
I said I can tell you there's a couple of different
ways. other people have done it And you
can do it either one of those or your own way,
or however you want. I said you know,
my advice
is
that it's not permanent. If it doesn't work,
you can change it. They
took the troop and they made them into two
patrols And then,
before too long, we needed a third patrol
And they were at the point
where they had
three patrols of eight scouts in each one.
And then I'm showing them the roster. I said:
you've got, you know,
crossovers coming, Guess what?
What do you want to do?
And
so they decided to go from
three patrols to five.
Your patrol identity has been a moving target
for these guys And I think there's been some struggle with that
as they've grown. After a year
you would do it again. Of course, there's been
some challenges and difficulties along
the way. You changed your mind about
a couple of things. Where do you think
you're going to be a year from now?
I think the biggest changes were
in the year past, right? So
I think this year is going to be more
of us getting into
established traditions
rather than rapid changes
like we've had this year.
Well, Arlen, thanks so much for spending the time
with us again, And we're going to check in with you
in months to come
and see how things are going on. I'm glad
to hear everything's worked out well.
There's been challenges, like I said, but it's
been a lot of fun and I wouldn't have changed it
for sure.
Hey, thanks so much for listening to this
211th edition
of the Scoutmaster podcast.
Here's how you can keep in touch:
Read the blog at scoutmastercgcom
and, while you're there, you can subscribe
to receive updates to the blog by email.
You can get the Scoutmaster app
on Google Play or in the iTunes
App Store And that way
you can have all of the resources, the blog
polls, the videos, the podcasts,
all that stuff right there at your fingertips
on your mobile device. You can experience
the wonders-
I say the wonders- of scoutmastercgcom
through the vast
panorama of social media.
You can join the 4,900 folks
who like Scoutmaster blog on Facebook
and tweet, along with a chorus
of 950 tweeters on Twitter.
Pin the Pulture Toot in his pictures
proffered publicly, with
1,300 other prolific pinners
on Pinterest
And watch us, if you dare, at ScoutmasterCG
on YouTube. If none of that appeals to you,
well, you can join the 400 odd folks
who form the exclusive Scoutmaster
Circle on Google Plus.
Now, if you can't face Facebook,
if Twitter makes you what Bitter,
That's right. If you have
no interest in Pinterest,
you don't put the? U in YouTube and you're a minus
when it comes to Google Plus, Don't worry,
That's alright. Bunky, Zoom
into the late 90s and send me an email.
You can get in touch with me,
Clark Green, at
Clark C-L-A-R-K-E
at
ScoutmasterCGcom.
The Scoutmaster blog
and the Scoutmaster podcast and all the rest
of this mess
are not official publications of the Boy Scouts
of America. nor are they endorsed
or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America,
or any other scouting organization for that matter.
I'm pretty sure they have
better things to do, aren't you? No, it's
just me talking into a microphone,
trying to lend a hand to Scout Leaders
and have a little bit of fun along the way. Speaking of fun,
here's our founder,
Sir Robert Baden-Powell.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and good camping.
Well, thank you, sir,
Until next time, everyone.